so about what would Diplo do first of
all there are people out there who don't
know who Diplo is yes so maybe you
should explain who is Diplo for those
people and what the show is about well
those people are generally of a certain
age yeah usually um Diplo is I put out
and so I I tell them he's kinda like the
Frank Sinatra of electronic dance music
right he is it's a way to get an older
person interested in something that they
would despise yeah this is this this is
one of the least impressive shows to
brag about to your older relatives
because it always starts with when do
you have a new show well well yes Aunt
Rose I do well what's it about well do
you know who Diplo is right which is
Julia met with some version of dip what
yeah yeah and then sounds like a
medication yeah yeah and then I try to
hit him well do you know what EDM is and
then that's usually metal like that's a
procedure yeah but he is in reality a
worldwide juggernaut he has been behind
so many massive hits he had worked with
everybody in the business everybody from
yet I mean Justin Bieber Madonna Beyonce
everybody if you've listened to popular
music at all in the last ten years
you've heard his music so you play Diplo
in this show which is very funny I want
to make that clear there's a great
comedy moments in the show what's
interesting is that Diplo wanted you to
play him is that right yeah hey it all
came from a just a commercial I've done
for him on a lark for his Mad Decent
block party tour and vice land after
that came to us and said we think this
is a series at first I didn't see it I
was like how old come on it's just and
then I thought wait a minute it is a
series we could do like you know musical
genius terrible at life right and Diplo
you know for his part said you'll just
just make it look completely ridiculous
right you know kind of look like the
real Diplo today you guys have there's a
similarity there there's you know so
it's within reason that you would play
dude I could be a stunt double yeah
and so is this I'm you talked about
explaining this role to your family
you've had different how is it in
general explaining your career to older
relatives I always have a hard time with
that like just explaining what it is I
do you know why I rub my nipple at the
top of the show which apparently no one
I just I don't understand why I do that
but how do you explain do they
understand it throughout your career
when you talk to your older relatives
and you talk to them about what you're
doing they um do they get it are they
supportive I mean they they try to be
supportive I mean you know I've been
doing this for 25 years now is just kind
of crazy so the fact that I'm still
doing it yeah you know I'm now going for
the backup career as a porn star with
the mustache yeah but I have seen your
work and you're very good but you know
my dad god bless him you played baseball
before was born and you worked for the
phone company for 20-something years
watches what would Diplo do and says you
know I'm not I'm not sure it's a show
I'd watch if you weren't on it but that
was pretty funny yeah so I'm like that's
a compliment I think from yeah yeah yeah
that's that's the that's what you get
from parents yeah exactly
backhanded compliment like my dad said
to me once oh I see what it is you're
doing you're making a living off of
something that should probably be
treated and he meant it like yes there's
a chemical imbalance but it's working
for you yes yes so well myself yeah
exactly okay dad Thanks
you